und damit kommen wir hier zum nächsten
tagesordnungspunkt
die cdu csu fraktion hat einen antrag
eingereicht auch hier geht es um die
reaktionen deutschlands auf den
angriffskrieg russlands und zwar geht es
darum wie sanktionen umgesetzt werden
können die union kritisiert dass
deutschland da langsamer ist als andere
länder
und das liegt unter anderem daran dass
wir die behörden die
eigentumsverhältnisse erst klären wollen
bevor sie sanktionen umsetzen und zum
beispiel in italien reicht da ein
begründeter verdacht aus und deswegen
fordert hier die union dass das auch in
deutschland schneller gehen sollte
und erster redner dafür ist nun auch
günter krings unionsfraktionen
damen und herren der angriffskrieg
russlands gegen die ukraine hat die
weltpolitik aber auch unsere nationale
politik grundlegend verändert wir spüren
dass in fast jeder debatte hier auch in
dieser sitzungswoche
die brutale dimension dieses
barbarischen krieges sie verlangt nach
einer raschen besonders deutlichen und
konsequenten antwort der
völkergemeinschaft
neben der unterstützung der ukraine in
ihrem freiheitskampf
durch waffenlieferungen sind
wirtschaftssanktionen und ähnliche
maßnahmen die wichtigste ja und die
potenziell wirksamste
reaktionsmöglichkeit unseres
rechtsstaats gegen die russische
aggression weil die mutter es
reicht es hat nicht wenn wir im verbund
der europäischen union sanktionen nur
aussprechen
sondern sie müssen in den einzelnen
mitgliedstaaten auch mit klarer kante
durchgesetzt werden
bislang haben sich die sanktionen in
unserem land aber zu einem nicht
unerheblichen teil als zahnloser tiger
erwiesen
andere staaten wie italien gehen hier
viel konsequenter und damit auch
erfolgreicher vor aber beispielsweise
auch ein gericht auf den fidschi inseln
hat jüngst die beschlagnahme einer
elegischen superyacht an ordnet nachdem
es dazu auch nach dem dazu auch die
vereinigten staaten dieses land ersucht
haben
unterdessen können in deutschland
aufgrund unklarer zuständigkeiten
aufgrund fehlender
ermächtigungsgrundlagen oligarchen mit
ihren flugzeugen oder yachten immer noch
das weite suchen meine damen und herren
wenn unsere sanktionsmaßnahmen bei den
betroffenen russischen oligarchen
nur ein müdes lächeln auslösen oder wenn
wir gar zum sicheren hafen für putins
wirtschafts freunde werden dann wollen
wir in der union das jedenfalls nicht
genehmen meine damen und herren
und es ist daher schon mal gut wenn die
ampel koalition nun endlich einen
eigenen gesetzentwurf zur besseren
rechtsetzung vorliegt wirst nicht
ersichtlich warum man das in die späten
abendstunden versteckt sie machen aber
damit zumindest einen kleinen schritt in
die richtige richtung aber mit unserem
antrag zeigen wir ihnen allerdings was
wirklich nötig ist damit die sanktionen
spürbar und wirksam werden
so können vermögenswerte werte wie teure
häuser oder schiffe der russischen
oligarchen in unserem land bislang
lediglich nicht veräußert oder eben
gegen geld ansonsten verwertet werden
aber sie können ihm weiter ungestört
genutzt werden wir wollen die eigentümer
von jeglicher auch unentgeltlicher auch
privater nutzung definitiv und
konsequent ausschließen
und wir sehen ja auch ein
offensichtlichen widerspruch hier wenn
geldvermögen in keiner form mehr genutzt
werden können ist es eben weltfremd bei
real werten noch künstlich zwischen
verbotener verwertungen und erlaubte
nutzung zu unterscheiden das ist ja
geradezu die einladung zum unterlaufen
der sanktionen
wie sollen denn unsere behörden etwa
feststellen ob eine yacht zu einem
privaten segeltörn einen hafen verlässt
oder eben um im ausland dann ungestört
verkauft zu werden
nur wenn wir wie etwa in italien die
eigentümer von jedweder nutzung
ausschließen werden die sanktionen in
deutschland auch erfolgreich sein meine
damen und herren gerade bei
luxusimmobilien in mutmaßlich russischer
hand brauchen wir auch mehr klarheit und
transparenz über die
eigentumsverhältnisse
deswegen muss der bundesjustizminister
als zuständiges ressort jetzt endlich
auf die länder zugehen um sie wirksam
bei einer schnelleren umsetzung des
datenbank grundbuchs unterstützen das
steht seit acht jahren im
bundesgesetzblatt die umsetzungsfrist
ist in der tat noch nicht ausgelaufen
aber jetzt müssen wir da wirklich einen
zahn zulegen und das muss dann auch mit
unterstützung des bundes passieren da
kann man nicht nur einfach auf die
länder verweisen dass es auch unserer
verantwortung als bunt hier zu
unterstützen hier zu helfen weil damit
die große koalition hat in der letzten
wahl würde schon einiges erreicht zur
bekämpfung der geldwäsche das waren
wirklich quantensprünge die wir da ins
gesetz geschrieben haben aber auch da
gibt es noch einiges zu tun wir wollen
etwa eine geldwäscheverdachts datenbank
die vor immobiliengeschäften auch vom
notar heranzuziehen ist und wir wollen
schluss damit machen das immobilien
geschäfte mit bargeld abgewickelt werden
können meine damen und herren die
allermeisten menschen in diesem land
kaufen maximal einmal wenn überhaupt in
ihrem leben ein haus oder eine wohnung
uns erwarten bestimmt nicht dass sie das
mit einem geldkoffer in der hand machen
können
meine damen und herren uns ist es ferner
wichtig dass wir auch den medien
organisationen wie der russische staat
zum zwecke der kriegspropaganda in
deutschland lenkt die materielle
arbeitsgrundlage entziehen wenn
russische nachrichtendienste bestimmen
was gesendet wird wenn internet trolle
ihre zynischen fake news von berlin aus
nach deutschland und in viele andere
teile der welt schicken dann geht es
dabei nicht um pressefreiheit sondern
müssen wir das konsequent stoppen weil
damen und herren
und schließlich das kann ich kleinen des
hauses nicht ersparen dürfen wir nicht
vergessen dass unsere sanktionen vor dem
hintergrund des nahezu beispiellosen
völker rechtsbruchs und der nicht enden
wollenden russischen kriegsverbrechen
für ihre volle wirksamkeit
nicht nur ökonomisch spürbar sein müssen
der zweck ist denn gerade dass sie dem
russischen volk insgesamt zeigen dass
seine politische führung international
vollkommen geächtet ist und dass seine
politische führung irland in die
absolute isolation führt
und genau deshalb sieht unser antrag
auch vor dass wir die hohe gehälter von
ehemaligen regierungsmitgliedern
streichen wenn sie genau diese ächtung
von aggressoren unterlaufen wie aktuell
gerd schröder der für den kriegstreibern
kämpft immer noch öffentlich verständnis
zeigt diese kompanie kann nicht mit
deutschen bank sohns ansprüchen belebt
er gelobt werden und so ausgestattet
werden dass
verhalten
dieses altkanzlers schadet dem ansinnen
und dem schadet dem ansehen deutschlands
massiv das verhalten dieses altkanzlers
schadet dem ansehen deutschlands massiv
auch weil das geeignet ist die wichtige
psychologische wirkung unserer
sanktionen abzuschwächen und ein letzter
gedanke man kann sich eben nicht
gleichzeitig von putin aushalten lassen
und vom deutschen steuerzahler
alimentieren lassen darunter
güter klingt der rechtspolitische
sprecher der unionsfraktion war der
erste redner in dieser debatte in der es
um reaktionen des rechtsstaats in dem
fall des deutschen rechtsstaats auf den
angriffskrieg russlands gegen die
ukraine geht nächster redner jens
zimmermann aus der spd-fraktion und da
ist er digital politischer sprecher
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
im angriffskrieg russlands gegen die
ukraine haben wir als reaktion jede
menge diskussionen hier im haus auch
diese woche es geht um die frage von
energielieferungen es geht um die frage
von waffenlieferungen es geht um die
einheit innerhalb europas aber wir haben
eben auch die wirtschaftliche
perspektive dieses konflikts und
deswegen ist es sehr wichtig dass wir
hier auch sehr frühzeitig entschieden
die sanktionen gegenüber russland
erlassen haben und jetzt geht es
natürlich auch darum diese sanktionen
durchzusetzen und wir begrüßen da
durchaus den antrag der unionsfraktionen
die genau dies auch fordern sie fordern
die bundesregierung auf tätig zu werden
das ist gut und richtig und ich freue
mich sehr die kolleginnen hier neben mir
dass die bundesregierung genau das
bereits getan hat weshalb wir als ampel
fraktionen in dieser woche auch das
erste sanktion durchsetzungs gesetz in
den bundestag eingebracht haben
wir haben es gestern im finanzausschuss
diskutiert und werden es heute ich geb's
zu herr kollege ein bisschen zu später
stunde hier auch gemeinsam diskutieren
aber es ist richtig denn wir müssen
beispielsweise dafür sorgen wenn wir
immobilien hier in deutschland
vorfinden die russischen oligarchen
gehören die möglicherweise auch aber
verschleiert werden über
familienmitglieder über windige
konstruktionen dann müssen wir das
aufklären und da brauchen wir am ende
vollkommen richtig mehr transparenz und
das ein immobilien register wer eine
hervorragende sache und ich freue mich
sehr
ich freue mich sehr dass wir gemeinsam
die ampel koalitionäre genau das auch
bereits im koalitionsvertrag
vereinbart haben und deswegen wird es
das auch geben
was mich an dem antrag der union dann
aber doch auch so ein bisschen
überrascht ist das ist ja an ganz vielen
stellen so eine 180 grad kehrtwende
also
wenn ich da an die letzten jahre
zurückdenke da wer bei so einem antrag
den sie selbst jetzt stellen da hier
hätte es mit sicherheit die sind als
überbordende bürokratie
das ist stellt immobilienbesitzer
beispielsweise unter generalverdacht das
wäre so die klaviatur gewesen die man da
normalerweise von ihnen liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen erwartet hätte
aber es ist ja auch schön dass so etwas
schlimmes wie dieser konflikt aktuell
der krieg russlands gegen die ukraine
auch bei ihnen da zu einem
positionswechsel geführt hat und
deswegen unterstützen wir das auch und
werden vieles davon in unserem gesetz
auch mit aufnehmen liebe kollegen
was ich da auch durchaus spannend finde
ist dass sie ja sagen also bargeld beim
immobilienerwerb das wollen sie in
zukunft verbieten das ist auch finde ich
eine hervorragende idee aber auch da
muss ich sagen sie haben sich doch hier
immer als die großen verteidiger des
wagens aufgeführt und jetzt wollen sie
den leuten da ans bargeld dran ich bin
mir nicht ganz so sicher wie lange wie
lange dieser wut am ende dann auch
halten wird aber wir werden sie dass er
sehr gerne beim wort nehmen wir haben
und das ist klar hier in deutschland
eine schwierige situation weil es ist
mal wieder der föderalismus ich kann
ihnen da leider nur zustimmen herr
kollege krings wir haben 16 bundesländer
die an dieser stelle auch viele
zuständigkeiten haben wir sagen ganz
klar es braucht bei der sanktions
durchsetzung am ende auch klare bundes
zuständigkeiten das ist leider wie so
oft nicht ganz so einfach da sind wir
aber dran aber am ende des tages muss
auch klar sein dass zuständigkeit bei
den ländern liegt das werden wir in
unserem gesetzentwurf den wir heute
abend einbringen dann auch noch mal klar
ziehen denn am ende des tages ist eine
konsequente durchsetzung der sanktionen
ein wichtiger beitrag im kampf der
ukraine gegen russlands und am ende auch
für alle zukünftigen aggressoren eine
ganz klare warnung und ich glaube das
ist etwas was aus dieser ganzen
situation in jedem fall jeder auf der
auf dem zettel haben muss der in zukunft
ähnliches plant es wird eine scharfe
eine klare eine entschiedene reaktion
all derer geben die hier diese
sanktionen am ende klar durchsetzten und
ich hoffe dass wir dann in deutschland
bei der durchsetzung von sanktionen auch
an der spitze stehen werden herzlichen
dank
jetzt stimmen aus der spd fraktion in
einer debatte die initiiert wurde durch
einen antrag der unionsfraktion es geht
um durchgriffsmöglichkeiten und du
härtere umsetzung beispielsweise von
sanktionen etwa gegen russische
oligarchen aber einige punkte darüber
hinaus und dazu jetzt kein gottschalk
aus der afg fraktion frau präsidentin
verehrte damen und herren die cdu csu
trifft hat durchaus einen nagel auf den
kopf aber wie es der kollege zimmermann
angedeutet hat es ist stellt eine 180
grad wende der cdu in vielen
themenbereichen die ich ja abarbeiten
möchte da aber der reihe nach bereits im
juni 2020 hat die europäische kommission
eine stellungnahme herausgegeben wie
beim einfrieren von vermögenswerten in
der eu agiert werden sollen das
bundesfinanzministerium definiert auf
dieser grundlage das einfrieren von
vermögenswerten als verhinderung der
verwendung von wirtschaftlichen
ressourcen für den erwerb von geld waren
oder dienstleistungen
das behauptet beziehungsweise das
bedeutet dass beispielsweise sie haben
es beschrieben eine villa weiterhin
bewohnt werden darf sie darf allerdings
nicht verkauft vermietet oder grundbuch
rechtlich belastet werden erst wenn der
eigentümer der villa gegen dieses
sogenannte verfügungs verbot verstoßen
würde beispielsweise indem er versucht
die immobilie zu veräußern kann diese
beschlagnahmt werden oder wenn es einen
konkreten straftat im zusammenhang mit
der immobilie gibt dann kann im
strafrechtlichen sinne und verfahren die
immobilie eingezogen werden ansonsten
und das ist auch gut so gibt es nach dem
aktuellen recht in deutschland keine
möglichkeit dem auf der sanktionsliste
benannten eigentümer tatsächlich die
nutzung zu verbieten im gegensatz dazu
verehrte kollegin der cdu csu in ihrem
antrag nehmen sie hier entsprechend eine
komplette ausstellt ein komplettes aus
dem angeln heben der grundgesetzlich
garantierten position des artikel 14
satz 1 absatz 1 satz 1 von meine damen
und herren gerade das eigentum den
vielen anderen grundrechten
unterscheidet uns von einem grund
rechtsstaat und meine damen und herren
sie können darüber diskutieren aber
selbst straffällig gewordenen
schwerkriminellen oder mördern in
deutschland wird das eigentum nicht
genommen meine damen und herren das ist
eine grundgesetzlich garantierte
position und die können wir an dieser
stelle nicht so einfach über den haufen
werfen denn das ist die garantie des
deutschen rechtsstaates
somit stellt ihr antrag verehrte
kollegin von der cdu/csu einen massiven
eingriff in die eigentumsrechte da den
eben wie schon beschrieben nicht mal
andere hier wieder fahren denn der
verfassungsrechtliche begriff des
eigentums vielleicht eine kleine
nachhilfestunde an dieser stelle geht
weit weit über den privatrechtlichen
eigentumsbegriff hinaus und ist auch
sehr eindeutig im grundgesetz gefasst
enteignung funktionieren nämlich nur
dann wo das allgemeinwohl vorrang hat
und auch dann geht es nur mit
entsprechenden entschädigung oder wollen
sie ein ernstes am ende des tages weil
sie hier enteignen wollen plakativ den
starken mann spielen wollen am ende des
tages dann einen oligarchen auch noch
entschädigen das würde glaube ich ein
bisschen den gesagt man dem fass den
boden aus schlagen die frage mich
sowieso an dieser stelle was aus der
partei der sozialen marktwirtschaft für
die eigenverantwortung und eigentum mal
ein hohes gut wahr geworden ist eine für
mich so sozialistische forderung
aufzustellen
bei allem verständnis für harte
sanktionen gegen die verantwortlichen
und unterstützer des angriffskrieges das
sagt auch meine fraktion sind wir am
trotz am ende trotzdem nicht in der spz
in der 1945 bis 1946 unter dem begriff
der bodenreform eine entschädigungslose
enteignung durchgeführt wurde meine
damen und herren also was ist aus ihnen
und ihrer stellung zur sozialen
marktwirtschaft und den eigentumsrechten
geworden da müssen sie in sich gehen
teilte kollegen der cdu csu
am ende möchte ich noch einige worte
unter punkt 5 10 in ihren antrag sagen
zu herrn schröder es scheint vor allem
ein sozialdemokratisches problem zu sein
und beispielsweise die fans den ex
kanzler schröder ich zitiere als tut den
preußen kamerad bezahlt wird im übrigen
ex kanzler kern ebenfalls sozialdemokrat
in österreich verwendet sich als
aufsichtsrat der russischen staatsbahn
rzd die afg hat schon in ihrem
grundsatzprogramm
20/16 verabschiedet sich gegen
derartigen lobbyismus auszusprechen
weshalb wir die idee übergangsgeld und
ruhegehalt
einzufrieren an dieser stelle nicht
diskutieren sie es wäre gar nicht erst
gekommen wenn es an fristen für
regierungsmitglieder gegeben hätte nicht
vom staatsamt in ein aufsichts
anzutreten meine damen und herren
manchmal
macht es eben sinn nicht der presse oder
ihre eigenen meinung über uns zu folgen
sondern einfach mal in das
grundsatzprogramm der fdp zu gucken da
steht viel kluges drin weil es ihm viel
leid hier erspart hätte vielen dank
carlotta der finanzpolitische sprecher
der fdp fraktion hat den früheren
bundeskanzler gerhard schröder
angesprochen in dem antrag der union
heißt es unter anderem das frühere
mitglieder der bundesregierung
übergangsgeld beziehungsweise das
ruhegehalt verlieren können sollen wenn
sie in ihrem amt dem ansehen der
bundesrepublik deutschland erheblichen
schaden zufügen jetzt spricht franziska
brantner parlamentarische
staatssekretärin beim
bundeswirtschaftsminister
die seit beginn des furchtbaren krieges
verhängt wurden auch effektiv
durchzusetzen
und deswegen läuft in deutschland die
aktions durchsetzung ganz gut wir haben
extra eine task force eingerichtet aber
wir heben haben eben auch gemerkt wo die
lücken sind wir haben lücken und
deswegen legen wir jetzt auch an
sanktions durchsetzungs gesetze numero
eins vor dass heute abend dann auch hier
debattiert wird und ich möchte wenige
neuerungen gesondert erwähnt wir
besuchen endlich die zuständigen
behörden zeugen zu vernehmen
beweismittel sicherzustellen wohnungen
und geschäftsräume zu durchsuchen oder
öffentliche register einzusehen wir
führen zwei neue möglichkeiten zur
sicherstellung von vermögensgegenständen
1 drittens verbessern wir die
möglichkeiten konnten abzufragen oder
wertpapierdepots zu ermitteln und wir
viertens wir werden sanktionierten
personen bei strafandrohungen dazu
verpflichten ihr vermögen unverzüglich
offenzulegen und letztens fünftens wir
verbessern auch den
informationsaustausch zwischen den
behörden über die föderalen ebenen
hinweg aber dabei werden wir es nicht
belassen wir arbeiten schon am zweiten
reformpaket und deswegen arbeiten wir
hier so schnell wie seit jahrzehnten
nicht der fall war und wir haben
uns ein nationales register für vermögen
unklarer herkunft
vorgenommen die schafe einer
hinweisgeber stelle viele weitere war's
maßnahmen wir brauchen nämlich ein
dauerhaft wirksames sanktions
durchsetzungs gesetze und wir werden
auch die bekämpfung der geldwäsche damit
gleichzeitig verstärken liebe
unionsfraktionen auch ich freue mich bei
ihnen die zeitenwende zu sehen und
deswegen geht ihr antrag eindeutig in
die richtige richtung sie haben viele
vorschläge die wir schon umsetzen und
weitere die im zweiten paket kommen ich
sag mal stichwort immobilien barkauf
verhindern oder die frage käufer wo
sitzt vielleicht die notare oder die
frage was passiert eigentlich wenn man
auch nach einer langen c dur immer noch
nicht feststellen kann leben eigentlich
ein betrieb gehört das sind fragen die
sie auf machen die wir auch beantworten
wollen von daher hoffe ich dass sie sich
konstruktiv in die gesetze einbringen
auch in das was wir heute abend hier
gemeinsam diskutieren können gerne
änderungsanträge schreiben darauf freuen
wir uns und ich freue mich auf die
unterstützung und möchte gerne enden mit
einem zitat von ivan krastev er hat
gesagt keeping the money auf korab
liedes in new bands das ist irre leistet
korruption ich übersetze das geld von
korrupten liedern in ihren banken zu
haben zivilisiert nicht diese korrupten
lieder es korrumpiert sie und deswegen
ist es unsere aufgabe sicher zu stellen
dass wir generell
hier endlich auch aufräumen ich danke
ihnen freue mich auf die zeit ab und
gewannen
franziska brantner parlamentarische
geschäftsführerin beim bundesminister
für wirtschaft und klimaschutz und die
nun der nächste redner kommt aus der
fraktion die linke und das ist pascal
leyser unter anderem sprecher für
dienstleistungs politik
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine
damen und herren man kann es nicht oft
genug wiederholen der krieg russlands
gegen die ukraine ist ein verbrechen und
durch nichts zu rechtfertigen
die linke spricht sich deshalb auch
weiterhin für konsequente sanktionen
gegen die russiche führungseliten aus
damit dieser krieg umgehend beendet wird
und russland seine truppen zurückzieht
doch mit blick auf die umsetzung genau
dieser sanktionen ist die bilanz
deutschlands bislang äußerst beschämt
nach der letzten veröffentlichten
zwischenbilanz der eu kommission dass
man brille hat allein frankreich
vermögenswerte in höhe von 23 5
milliarden euro eingefroren in belgien
waren es zehn milliarden euro italien
waren es immerhin noch 1,1 milliarden in
deutschland zum gleichen zeitpunkt
lediglich 43
341 millionen euro ich finde das ein
klares zeichen dass hier endlich
konsequent auch in deutschland gehandelt
werden muss
alle wissen aber auch dass das alles
tiefer liegende gründe hat denn wer über
das versagen bei der umsetzung der
sanktionen klagt und das zu recht darf
nicht darüber schweigen dass deutschland
schon lange als paradies für geldwäsche
und schmutziges geld aus aller welt geht
wir als linke haben in den vergangen
jahren immer wieder auf dieses problem
hingewiesen nicht als einzige aber ich
glaube am vehementesten dort passiert
ist so gut wie nichts auch die
konsequente umsetzung der sanktionen die
russische oligarchen scheitert bisher
unter anderem daran dass die
tatsächlichen besitzverhältnisse
größerer vermögenswerte häufig mit
extrem undurchsichtigen
unternehmensstrukturen verschleiert
werden und dass die offenlegung der
verfügungsberechtigten nicht wirkliche
erzwungen werden kann und ist so absurd
das bis heute möglich ist
immobilienkäufe unternehmenserwerben mit
bargeld in unbegrenzter höhe vornehmen
zu können das so kofferweise schmutziges
geld weiß gewaschen werden kann
ich sage mit all dem muss nicht schluss
sein und zwar völlig unabhängig davon ob
es um die durchsetzung von sanktionen
gegen die eliten russlands hoffentlich
auch um sanktionen gegen verantwortliche
anderer verbrecherischer kriege oder um
die bekämpfung von geldwäsche und
organisierter kriminalität geht
uns allen fällt doch jetzt auf die füße
dass die große koalition den letzten
jahren dass weder wolfgang schäuble noch
olaf scholz als finanzminister den kampf
gegen geldwäsche und finanzkriminalität
jemals ernsthaft aufgenommen haben ich
will sich von der union an dieser stelle
daran erinnern dass es wolfgang schäuble
war der als finanzminister für den
desaströsen start der von joe
intelligence unit verantwortlich war die
uns in der folge bekanntermaßen riesige
probleme bereitet hat
märz linke haben nicht nur zu lange auf
diese probleme hingewiesen wir haben
auch immer der konkrete vorschläge
unterbreitet bereits im jahr 2013 haben
wir die einrichtung einer
bundesfinanzpolizei als wirtschafts und
finanz ermittlungsbehörde vorgeschlagen
und zuletzt 2009 haben wir einen
masterplan gegen geldwäsche und
finanzkriminalität vorgelegt und ich
freue mich liebe kollegen und kollegen
von der cdu csu dass sie jetzt doch eine
ganze reihe unserer vorschläge
übernommen haben nachdem sich dagegen so
lange gesträubt
ich könnte zum schluss frau präsidentin
hier als linke lehnen jeden fall weiter
druck dafür machen dass sanktionen gegen
die russischen eliten konsequent
umgesetzt werden und dass endlich
schluss damit gemacht wird dass
deutschland ein paradies für geldwäsche
und finanzkriminalität ist vielen dank
für ihre aufmerksamkeit
pascal leyser für die linksfraktion und
weiter geht es mit maximilian mordhorst
aus der fdp-fraktion und wir reden immer
noch über hilfreiche
maßnahmen gehen etwa russische oligarch
und kollegen ich versuche mich heute
nicht zu sehr in der parteipolitischen
profilierung zu verlieren denn ich
glaube das thema ist viel zu ernst dafür
was aber teilweise insinuiert wird dass
unsere sanktionen die wir als paket
bisher beschlossen haben und die wir ja
auch schon zu einem großen teil sehr
wirksam durchsetzen ist glaube ich wenn
man sich die wirtschaftliche und soziale
lage in russland anschaut und wie sehr
dieses volk unter diesem regime leiden
muss er nicht ganz der realität
entsprechend glaube wir finden schon
wichtige und gute maßnahmen die wir auch
gegen russland durchsetzen und die auch
wirksam sind dennoch möchte ich gar
nicht viel darum herum ihnen dass wir
für teile ihres antrags durchaus
sympathien haben es gibt gute gute
punkte die man die sie vorbringen mit
denen wir in deutschland die sanktionen
besser durchsetzen können wir werden
auch mit einem sanktions durchsetzungs
gesetz 2 das ganze noch weiter
voranbringen das einfrieren von
vermögenswerten bestimmte
offenbarungspflicht dafür habe ich
großen sympathie und wir werden deswegen
auch ganz konstruktiv das was sie heute
vorschlagen in unsere in unserem paket
wie wir die sanktionen durchsetzen
wollen weiter einfließen lassen ich
glaube das gehört zur ehrlichkeit und
zur gemeinsamkeit dabei wenn man gegen
russland und das risiko hin will dazu
dass die afd ziemliche probleme damit
hat wenn wir den verbleib russischer
gelder in deutschland besser aufklären
ist glaube ich auch offensichtlich ich
kann mir das jedenfalls sehr gut
vorstellen wir werden auch und ich muss
auch sagen ich habe auch persönliche
sympathie dafür dass wir darüber reden
ob ehemalige regierungsmitglieder noch
die mittlerweile günstling eines staates
sind der offensichtlich verbrecherisch
agiert ob die noch von uns alimentiert
werden sollten ich denke schon dass das
ein thema ist dass wir nochmal ernst auf
diskutieren müssen denn das gibt gerade
für die bundesrepublik deutschland
insgesamt kein gutes bild ab einkommen
möchte ich dann auch anmerken in ihrem
antrag der ein bisschen naja es wirkt
wie eine idee die man schon so länger in
der hardliner fraktion cdu csu hatte die
man jetzt mal so ein bisschen durch die
hintertür durch bringen möchte ich
glaube es ist der vorletzte punkt in
ihrer aufzählung sie möchten eine
geldwäscheverdachts datenbank einführen
sie möchten und da muss man das mal
erklärt sie möchten jeden menschen der
in deutschland wegen eines
vermögensdelikten verurteilt wurde dass
der in einer vergällt wäsche verdachts
datenbank abgespeichert wurden überprüft
werden kann das glaube ich ist in einem
staat der auch auf resozialisierung
setzt gerade bei vermögensdelikten ein
wirklich großes problem und das sollten
wir ablehnen insbesondere weil sie auch
nicht einmal auf das bereits laufende
europäische programm verweisen dass
bereits eine datenbank hat die von den
mitgliedsstaaten gespeist wird aber ganz
andere viel höher rechtsstaatliche
anforderungen als gier vorschlag hat
deswegen denke ich allein deswegen dass
sie antrag nicht ganz ausgereift ist
rechtsstaatlich auch sehr sehr schwierig
was sie dort vorschlagen
deswegen
will ich gar nicht die letzten zwei
minuten ausreizen sanktions
durchsetzungs gesetze sind angekündigt
wir werden das alles konstruktiv
einfließen lassen und ich freue mich
sehr dass die demokratischen fraktionen
dieses hauses sehr stark daran arbeiten
möglichst konstruktiv und gemeinsam eine
klare kante gegen russland weiterhin
beizubehalten und die menschen lockte
ihn bestmöglich zu unterstützen
vielen dank
sagt maximilian mordhorst aus der
fdp-fraktion
und ihm wird jetzt folgen carlos kasper
aus der spd fraktion also ampel
kombination wird gerade
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte kolleginnen und kollegen liebe
unionsabgeordnete man muss immer wieder
staunen waren sie eigentlich mit solch
einem antrag um die ecke kommt es ist
doch seltsam vergangenen donnerstag legt
der finanzminister ein gesetzesentwurf
zur besseren durchsetzung der sanktionen
vor und exakt eine woche danach fällt
ihnen auch mal ein was zum thema zu
sagen zu müssen nur stunden bevor wir
hier das neue sanktions durchsetzungs
gesetz in erster lesung beraten werden
ich weiß nicht ob sie mit so einer
leistung zufrieden sind aber ich wäre es
zumindest nicht
und wenn man sich den gesetzesentwurf
der ampel mal gegenüberstellt zu ihrem
antrag stellt man fest mensch die haben
ja eine große übereinstimmung ich würde
sogar sagen sie haben wieder mal
abgeschrieben
schauen wir doch mal genauer 1.2 wollen
sie eine anzeigepflicht für
sanktionierte personen über vorhandene
vermögenswerte wir werden das in § 23a
außenwirtschaftsgesetz regel im punkt 5
wollen sie eine eigenständige
rechtsgrundlage für ermittlungen und
beschlagnahmung von vermögen das werden
wir in den paragrafen 6 a ford folgende
außenwirtschaftsgesetz fest schreiben
und den punkt 7 wollen sie einen
verbesserten datenaustausch zwischen den
gehört wir werden das ebenfalls im
paragraph 24a wg ermöglichen also
also verehrte damen und herren um was
geht es denn eigentlich seit dem
überfall russlands auf die ukraine im
februar haben wir gemeinsam mit unseren
europäischen partnern starke
sanktionspaket verabschiedet muss hier
noch einmal ganz deutlich zu sagen die
sanktionen sind ein sehr effektives
mittel und sie zeigen bereits jetzt ihre
würfe aber
zur wahrheit gehört auch wir sind in
deutschland noch nicht gut genug bei der
umsetzung dieser sanktionen deswegen
wurde eine task force eingerichtet diese
hat nun einen ersten vorschlag
erarbeitet den wir heute auch in
gesetzesform hier beraten mit diesem
gesetz machen wir einen ersten schritt
zu einer besseren datenübermittlung
zwischen den behörden stärken die
kompetenzen in diesem bereich und klären
ausdrücklich zuständigkeiten und genau
deshalb können wir ihren antrag leider
nicht zustimmen weil sie sich vor klaren
aussagen drücken wer hier eigentlich die
sanktionen umsetzen sollen
aber uns ist auch klar dass wir dann
auch noch tiefere reformen auf den weg
bringen müssen wir brauchen ein echtes
und stark so meine damen und herren das
machen wir nicht gerne aber es muss sein
denn
carlos kasper müssen wir jetzt
unterbrechen es gibt andernorts wichtige
dinge die wollen wir ihnen nicht
vorenthalten und danach geht's auch
wieder zurück in den bundestag bis
später